[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous j'espère
que vous allez bien nous sommes le jeudi
9 février voici le programme de ce soir
du 23 au 26 février aura lieu la 7e
édition du Mondial d'improvisation
junior à Trappes ça se déroulera dans
deux lieux le conservatoire de musique
et de danse et à la Merise et ce sont si
jeunes Trappistes de Déclic Théâtre qui
représenteront la France ils devront
affronter la Suisse le Québec et la
Belgique comment se prépare-t-il à cette
échéance nous aurons avec nous leur
coach Hamel Amiez
et Baptiste donte J-5 pour la Saint
Valentin dans les Yvelines vous pourrez
célébrer l'amour en dansant au Musée
départemental Maurice Denis de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le site propose
aux coupes de s'initier à la bachata au
milieu des œuvres le temps d'une soirée
et nous avons testé quelques pas pour
vous et pour ceux qui ne sont pas trop
denses le centre aqualudique castania de
Maurepas propose une soirée bien-être
avec son âge à cosy ou encore hammam
nous en parlerons avec le directeur de
Castalia format Vivier et puis comme
d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche du
week-end Gabriel Gonthier vous donnera
ses idées de sortie dans les Yvelines au
programme théâtre chant ou encore
spectacle nous parlerons aussi de
l'événement plaisir gaming qui aura lieu
ce samedi plusieurs tournois sont prévus
fortnite FIFA ou encore super smash bros
nous ferons le point avec Sébastien
horaire les lus à la jeunesse et avec
moi en plateau justement Amel Amziane la
coach de l'équipe junior de Déclic
Théâtre bonsoir et donc vous êtes avec
deux membres de l'équipe nanka Maïté et
Baptiste dond bonsoir bonsoir alors
comment est-ce que vous vous sentez à
deux semaines de l'échéance du Mondial
d'improvisation
[Musique]
et donc on parlera un peu plus des
préparations tout à l'heure ce
serait que nous
du centre aquality que Castalia Thomas
Vivi bonsoir alors ça fait 5 mois que le
centre aqualudique a ouvert ses portes
quelle est votre premier retour c'est
que ça passe vite contrairement à vous
une ouverture du coup le 8 septembre
2022 un accueil tout de suite des
usagers qui nous attendaient avec une
impatience une grande impatience et donc
c'est 60000 personnes qui ont plus fait
compter du coup le centre depuis
l'ouverture du coup de septembre 2022
des enfants des adultes des enfants qui
apprennent à nager des personnes qui
viennent se détendre notre magnifique
espace bien-être et des personnes qui
viennent se dépasser dans notre espace
fitness donc c'est que du positif pour
le moment et on parlera aussi de la
soirée que vous organisez pour la
Saint-Valentin mardi soir donc on en
parlera un peu plus tard dans cette
émission nous sommes aussi avec
Sébastien orger bonsoir alors vous êtes
élus à la jeunesse de plaisir et donc ce
samedi aura lieu plaisir gaming est-ce
que tout est prêt tout est prêt on a
fait le plein de joueurs on est en train
de finaliser l'installation donc voilà
m'annoncer une deuxième saison après le
succès de la première c'est encourageant
et donc on parlera des moments forts de
cette journée
demain matin le ciel sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble du département mais plutôt
bonne nouvelle les températures
remontent un peu on ne sera plus en
dessous de 0 degré il fera 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 3 degrés à Houdan
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
et laisser la place au soleil comptez
environ 9 degrés dans le secteur de
Mantes-la-Jolie 8 degrés à Houdan et 7
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Arnaud le
pont maintenant sur l'actualité dans les
Yvelines avec Céline Charles
Emmanuel Macron et volodymeersky ont
embarqué dans l'avion Falcon de la
présidente française ce jeudi matin
depuis l'aéroport de Vélizy-Villacoublay
dans les Yvelines ils sont arrivés à
Bruxelles quelques heures après pour se
rendre au sommet des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement de l'Union européenne le
président ukrainien devrait y demander
un nouveau renforcement de l'aide
militaire à l'Ukraine c'est insolite
plusieurs habitants de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ont reçu plus
d'une dizaine d'amendes de stationnement
chacun en cause un bug informatique de
l'application PayByPhone qui permet de
payer les forfaits post stationnement de
la ville ils se sont accumulés pendant
près d'un an et ont été envoyés
simultanément la semaine dernière la
municipalité assure cependant que les
usagers bénéficient d'un certain délai
pour effectuer leur démarche en ligne ou
envoyer leurs contestation par voie
postale
Île-de-France mobilité a annoncé une
campagne de remboursement pour les
détenteurs du Pass Navigo en cause la
dégradation de la qualité des services
des bus et métro entre septembre et
décembre 2022 et les retard des RER B et
D en 2022 vous pourrez vous faire
rembourser jusqu'à un mois d'abonnement
la plateforme de remboursement ouvrira
le 14 mars prochain le jeune joueur de
rugby 5 continents Enzo Benegal connaît
sa deuxième sélection en équipe de
France U20 l'encadrement tricolore a en
effet dévoilé l'équipe qui sera alignée
face à l'Irlande pour la deuxième
journée du Tournoi des 6 nations de
moins de 20 ans Enzo ben Mégal fait
partie des 15 joueurs qui disputeront le
match ce sera demain soir à 21h enfin si
vous êtes étudiant et que vous
recherchez un emploi sachez que les
services de l'État souhaite former et
recruter 3000 étudiants et jeunes pour
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 les postes concernent les métiers
de la sécurité privée pour la
surveillance des abords des
manifestations ou encore le contrôle de
sécurité à l'entrée des stades la
formation de 106 heures est gratuite et
rémunérée pour en bénéficier vous devez
vous inscrire comme demandeur d'emploi
sur une plateforme dédiée de Pôle emploi
et remplir le questionnaire sur le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et comme d'habitude si vous voyez une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
en pleine crise énergétique certaines
piscines ferment mais d'autres restent
ouvertes comme celle du centre
aqualudique Castalia de Maurepas Thomas
Vivi vous en êtes le directeur on en a
parlé brièvement en tout début de cette
émission alors comment est-ce que vous
organisez face à cette crise énergétique
qu'est-ce que vous mettez en place alors
nous avons la chance d'avoir un
établissement éco-responsable c'est dès
la conception du bâtiment c'était une
réflexion sur l'énergie et l'écologie
donc on a malgré tout baissé de 1 degré
du coup l'ensemble des bassins
agressions de la pataugeoire on a
sensibilisé notre personnel et les
clients sur le sujet et on a pris la
décision du coup de fermer le bassin
nordique donc jusqu'à la fin des
vacances de février pour le moment c'est
une décision assez bien comprise par les
clients on n'a pas de retour en négatif
sur le sujet et effectivement le
contexte justifié aujourd'hui ces
décisions alors vous l'avez dit c'est un
bâtiment qui a été conçu façonné de
façon à ce que ça soit
sobre et énergétiquement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus l'eau
est récupérée des bateaux
en bon d'être du coup mise en réseau des
eaux usées le bassin nordique du coup
extérieur a été exposé enfin a été
explosé plein sud de manière à profiter
des rayons du soleil il y a une
couverture du coup qui est mise sous les
soirs sur le bassin également extérieur
pour pour éviter la perdition de chaleur
tout un tas de petites choses qui permet
aujourd'hui effectivement de réduire la
facture à la fin du mois et alors vous
avez enregistré combien d'entrées en 5
mois alors en 2022 on a 60 000 personnes
qui ont fréquenté des établissements
avec les scolaires du coup qui est une
partie importante de fréquentation donc
c'était très bons résultats au vu du
contexte et donc ce sont des personnes
qui viennent principalement de Maurepas
ou d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on capte
effectivement une grosse part de
Maurepas Élancourt notre mission du coup
2023 c'est de capter un petit peu des
habitants aux alentours
en faisant rayonner un petit peu plus
établissement sur un territoire un petit
peu un petit peu plus large et vous avez
plutôt des abonnements ou des entrées
libres en fait une grosse partie de
personnes viennent avec leur abonnement
donc on a des abonnements pour la
piscine pour la partie fitness et
bien-être aujourd'hui on approche les
1500 abonnés sur le centre ce qui est en
5 mois de très bons résultats et donc on
peut peut-être le préciser vous l'avez
dit il y a un espace forme avec une
salle de sport il y a un espace
bien-être avec son âge jacuzzi hammam et
un dernier espace l'espace bah à quoi
ludique enfin l'espace aquatique donc
avec plusieurs bassins qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne le mieux en fait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce qui ce qui fonctionne
très bien c'est qu'on a la chance
d'avoir un bassin d'activité qui nous
permet du coup d'accueillir des
scolaires dans le bassin sportif du
public dans le bassin ludique et des
activités donc le Polac aquatique marche
très bien le pôle bien-être également la
partie fitness est encore à des
développer mais c'est juste que quand on
parle de centre aqualudique dans
l'imaginaire de nos usagers c'est pas
forcément le
la partie chibi en premier dans les
enfin dans les esprits
quand vous dites il faudrait développer
la partie fitness c'est-à-dire il
faudrait collectif même si depuis
janvier ça va mieux mais c'est la partie
aujourd'hui où il nous reste encore à
travailler sur la communication pour que
les usagers sachent qu'à cet espace au
sein d'établissement et alors à
l'occasion de la Saint-Valentin vous
organisez une soirée spéciale pour les
amoureux qu'est-ce qui est prévu et bien
on va privatiser du coup l'espace
bien-être donc vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure l'espace bien-être de Castalia
c'est un c'est un c'est un espace qui
contient du coup trois sauna de hammam
un jacuzzi du coup extérieur et du coup
un bassin aqualauge donc c'est 40 cm
d'eau chauffée à 34 degrés du coup et
donc pour cette occasion là au privatise
l'espace pour les célibataires ou les
couples en amoureux et donc il y aura un
buffet à disposition des cocktails et
encore une fois la privatisation de
l'espace donc ils seront une trentaine
dans cet dans cette dans cet espace là
ça se passe comment des places sont
encore disponibles donc les réservations
se font chez nous en ligne sur mon
centre aquatique.com et donc c'est 20
euros pour les abonnés et 30 euros pour
les non abonnés ça vous tente autour de
la table une soirée privative au centre
coledicast
alia Sébastien
vous aussi vous êtes intéressé rendez
vous donc le 14 février à partir de 19h
donc on poursuit sur le thème de la
Saint Valentin après le sauna et le
hammam de la danse et proposé au Musée
départemental Maurice Denis de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye les amoureux sont
invités à prendre les bases de la
bachata alors est-ce que autour de ce
plateau vous connaissez ce que c'est la
bachata
mais pas beaucoup plus à peu près
c'est une danse qui vient de République
Dominicaine et donc en fait une dizaine
de couples pourront profiter d'un cours
donné par l'association un salbakis au
sein des œuvres de l'exposition femme du
musée Maurice Denis j'ai bien voulu
tester quelques pas pour vous je vous
laisse regarder
aujourd'hui on se trouve au musée
départementale Maurice Denis à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour un cours de
bachata en effet le musée organise le 14
février le jour de la Saint-Valentin une
initiation c'est parti
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
vous allez nous apprendre quelque part
de base je vais me forcer 12 ans
ça veut dire
[Musique]
et on va marquer à 4 et marquer à 8
marquez ça veut dire simplement je vais
faire un touch sur le pied ou je ne suis
pas en appli de poids de corps d'accord
1 2 3 et je note 4 d'accord
5 6 7 et 8 l'avant arrière mais encore
une fois vu qu'on était miroir donc si
j'avance vous préférez
3 et là je vais faire mon top juste à
côté
[Musique]
5 6 7 et 8 très bien et le même le même
pas qu'on va faire sur place
qu'on appelle un peu la montada c'est un
peu d'escalier et c'est comme si on dit
bouteille d'accord
2 3 et je touche 4 et je recommence 3
5 6 7 8
et on est sur des mouvements que ça part
qui s'apparente plus
de la danse urbaine que la bachata de
base qui est une base Dominicaine et mon
but à moi ça va être du coup de vous
mettre en valeur
une princesse le temps de 3 minutes à
peu près là je prends mon pouce vous
venez simplement poser sur le pouce et
moi je vais simplement venir ici
d'accord je me pose jamais une main
complète pourquoi parce que du coup là
vous vous sentez agresser c'est pas on
est d'accord ici je suis dans une phase
de respect je vais venir ici et vous
allez chercher la connexion
[Musique]
comptez 14 euros par personne pour deux
heures de cours de danse le soir de la
Saint-Valentin de 19h à 21h l'initiation
est réservée à une dizaine de couples
alors n'oubliez pas de vous inscrire si
vous êtes intéressé donc rendez-vous le
14 février pour apprendre les pas de
base qu'on vient de voir ensemble
merci beaucoup merci à vous à bientôt
voilà alors est-ce que ça vous donne
envie de tester la bachata
[Rires]
vous faites quoi comme danse de la danse
chez moi déjà pour me défouler et puis
j'ai fait de la salsa donc d'accord ça
me parle
Sébastien Thomas
on va passer à la partie loisir on va
parler jeux vidéo dans un instant c'est
dans la partie loisir
[Musique]
les fans de jeux vidéo ont rendez-vous
ce samedi 11 février au Palais des
Sports Pierre de Coubertin de plaisir
pour la deuxième édition du plaisir
gaming au programme tournoi sur PC et
console ou encore animation pour toute
la famille avec nous pour en parler
Sébastien alors plaisir gaming c'est de
10h à 21h quels seront les moments forts
de cette journée alors le moment fort
c'est le tournoi de jeux vidéo donc il
va réunir 120 joueurs aujourd'hui on a
120 joueurs donc sur quatre jeux donc
TFT donc qui est un jeu de ryot de Games
Super Smash Bros ultimate donc un jeu de
combat mais avec des personnages
Nintendo il y a également un tournoi
donc sur fortnite et un dernier tournoi
sur Fifa de 2023 voilà donc il va réunir
donc pour Super Smash Bros et pour FIFA
48 joueurs pour les autres on est sur
sur une vingtaine pour le moment
et puis en parallèle de ça on aura des
des activités qu'on va proposer pour les
gens qui vont pouvoir venir nous voir et
qui ne participent pas au tournoi donc
des jeux en accès libre avec une zone
dédiée à des jeux diverses donc du
bowling il y aura des jeux de voiture il
y aura également une zone qui qui sera
plus axé sur la danse avec justement
puisqu'on avait un sujet sur la bachata
donc avec Just Dance et puis des
consoles rétro puisque on a voulu que ce
soit un événement familial et l'année
dernière comme ce fut le
castari Sega toutes ces consoles des
années des années on va dire des années
2090 2000 donc qui permettent aux
parents de de défier les enfants et aux
enfants de défier les parents aussi des
fois voilà sur des jeux qui qui
confondaient notre jeunesse enfin en
tout cas la mienne peut-être pas la
vôtre et donc vous avez parlé de
fortnite de FIFA de Super Smash Bros ce
sont des des jeux qui réunissent le plus
de monde aujourd'hui oui oui ce sont des
jeux en fait où il y a il y a une scène
eSport qui qui se développe et ce sont
des jeux où effectivement on n'a pas eu
de difficultés à faire le plein donc
c'est vraiment des jeux où il y a un
aspect de de vraiment de de sport c'est
vraiment le cas de le dire donc du coup
on est vraiment là dans le domaine du
sport des amateurs de jeux vidéo autour
du plateau je joue pas mal j'avoue je
joue pas mal notamment fortnite qui est
beaucoup ces trois dernières années là
ça a bien bien marché j'ai pas mal joué
il nous reste de la place sur fortnite
vous pouvez vous inscrire sur le sur le
site de la ville de plaisir c'est tout à
fait possible pourquoi pas ce sera avec
plaisir et donc vous avez des têtes
d'affiches pour animer un peu cette
journée oui alors en fait on aura on
travaille avec un enfin on travaille on
organise cette journée avec un
partenaire donc qui va en fait faire
l'animation donc on a une retransmission
sur écran géant on aura également des
des live twitch ou des lives
sur le site notamment de la ville ou sur
Facebook de la ville donc qui vont
retransmettre l'intégralité ou en tout
cas une grosse partie des tournois et
les temps forts de la de la journée et
donc est-ce qu'il y a des conditions
à part sur le sur la partie sur la
partie fortnite et TFT ou ce sont des
jeux sur pc donc là les joueurs doivent
Fener avec leur PC donc là on ouvrira
l'enceinte pour eux vers autour de 8h30
9h bah pour qu'il puisse installer leur
matériel FIFA et Smash Bros ultimate se
passe sur sur console et les consoles
sont fournies par par l'organisation
alors cette année c'est la deuxième
édition de plaisir gaming ça devient un
événement incontournable pour la ville
en tout cas ça un événement qui réunit
pas mal de pas mal de gens puisque
l'année dernière on avait également une
centaine de joueurs on a eu environ 700
7 à 800 personnes qui sont venues sur
toute la journée alors on était aussi
sur une sur une première édition donc on
a tiré des enseignements notamment au
niveau de la disposition dans le palais
des sports donc l'année dernière on
était vraiment sur l'entrée pour toute
la partie être gaming sera vraiment dans
la salle de tournoi donc vraiment dans
l'ambiance du trou noir
et
on a aussi revu un peu un peu toute
cette partie là donc
un événement incontournable en tout cas
un événement marquant et un événement
qui plaît au plaisir ouais qui plaît aux
jeunes puisque c'est vraiment dédié à la
jeunesse c'est vraiment pour eux c'est
tourner vous attendez combien de
personnes environ
bah là c'est une deuxième édition je
sais que j'ai pas mal de bouche à
oreille je suis moi-même d'ailleurs sur
le sur le discord du tournoi et je vois
qu'il y a de la discussion il y a de
l'émulation entre les joueurs donc et
puis il y a pas mal de de maintenant de
parents qui connaissent ça et puis j'ai
envie de dire la première édition est un
succès parce que il y a eu un vrai
bouche à oreille il y a eu une vraie
réponse à des à des attentes donc je
pense que la deuxième édition sera aussi
bien oui et donc si on n'est pas joueur
joueuse gamer gameuse on peut quand même
participer à cette journée puisque vous
l'avez dit il y a des animations pour
toute la famille exactement on a même
également pour les plus mélomanes on a
un atelier de animé par le Conservatoire
sur comment faire une musique de jeu
vidéo donc on peut même attirer voilà
des gens qui sont peut-être plus
éloignés du jeu vidéo mais qui aiment la
musique ou qui aime qui aime juste
l'ambiance ou quelque chose de festif
merci beaucoup Sébastien d'avoir accepté
notre invitation si vous êtes intéressé
le plaisir gaming c'est ce samedi 11
février de 10h à 21h au Palais des
Sports Pierre de Coubertin de plaisir
alors on va passer aux idées de sortie
avec Gabriel Gonthier Thomas vivier si
vous pouvez laisser la place gentiment à
Gabriel Gauthier pour qu'elle puisse
faire ses idées de sortie merci beaucoup
d'être venu en plateau avec nous pour
parler du centre aqualudique Castalia
Gabriel Gontier bonsoir
alors du coup vous avez d'autres idées
de sortie pour ce week-end pour nous
alors on commence par quoi ce soir on
commence avec du théâtre Mathilde et une
pièce qui se joue samedi soir au Théâtre
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans la
tendresse je libérer ce nous propose une
pièce à la fois drôle et sensible sur
une thématique essentielle et
d'actualité les hommes et la masculin
masculinité d'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'être un mec aujourd'hui c'est la
question centrale de la pièce une
réponse pas simple dans une société où
les hommes sont confrontés à la remise
en question des pseudos attributs du
genre masculin dans cette pièce la
virilité le patriarcat ou encore la
sexualité dominante sont remises en
question et avec ça les contradictions
de notre époque on écoute un extrait et
vous êtes à chaque fois que je tombe
amoureux j'ai ce rêve d'un amour qui
défile le temps ouais on vieillit
ensemble il y a pas de tresse j'ai peur
d'être déçu je me demande est-ce
que grandir c'est passer son temps à
perdre des gens je sais pas si je suis
quelqu'un dans ton souvenir je suis
quelqu'un de très enfin je suis pas
typique je suis assez banal je crois
et il reste trois dates Gabriel pour
cette pièce exactement ce soir la pièce
se joue à 19h30 vendredi et samedi soir
rendez-vous à 20h30 je crois que vous
étiez intéressé oui je vais l'avoir
demain avec mon lycée ben voilà c'est
vous avez un autre rendez-vous qui
risque d'intéresser les fans de lecture
Gabriel oui un rendez-vous Mathilde et
surtout un bon plan samedi de 10h à 17h
librairie culturel d'Alpha Park située
aux Clayes-sous-Bois vous propose une
large sélection de livres jeunesse à 1 €
cette opération est mise en place par
l'association Lire c'est partir et la
municipalité de la ville l'objectif agir
pour la lecture vaincre l'illettrisme et
encourager la découverte et c'est une
démarche qui s'inscrit dans la politique
de la ville puisque d'ailleurs elle a
déjà implanté des boîtes à livres dans
ces différents quartiers on poursuit
avec un rendez-vous musicalement Gabriel
le concours du tremplin des voix revient
pour la 8e saison alors le tremplin des
voix c'est un concours de chant organisé
par la voix en scène qui offre aux
candidat un accompagnement et une
expérience de la scène à noter qu'il y a
deux moyens de suivre le concours qui se
passe à Magny-les-Hameaux vous pouvez
prendre des places sur le site tremplin
des voix.com mais le projet se veut
également innovant Mathilde vous avez la
possibilité de visionner le concert en
direct sur YouTube et tout comme le jury
les spectateurs en physique ou sur
Youtube peuvent participer au vote et on
reste en musique avec un rendez-vous
familial à la Meurice de Trappes
dimanche avec du poil de la bête
hugobaret reste fidèle à ses valeurs et
propose un spectacle à destination du
jeune public entre champs et danse le
concert tourne autour des rythmes et des
mélodies du monde au-delà de la légèreté
de la musique il aborde des sujets
importants comme le respect
l'environnement et la découverte un
spectacle familial donc qui entraîne les
enfants aussi bien que les grands et on
tient on termine ces idées de sortie
avec le retour ce dimanche de la balade
d'hiver des 400 coups oui ce weekend
l'association Les 400 coups revient avec
ses balades d'hiver ce rendez-vous
incontournable propose 9 spectacles
vivants au travers de 10 communes et une
une quinzaine de lieux qui s'étendent
sur toute la vallée de la Seine
l'ambition de l'association et de
favoriser et de développer le spectacle
vivant sur le territoire le marathon
théâtre s'ouvre ce dimanche à 15h à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes avec la pièce mon
prof est un troll un spectacle familial
accessible aux enfants dès 7 ans et la
programmation se poursuit jusqu'au 25
février merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier
alors est-ce que vous avez une idée de
sortie qui vous tente plus qu'une autre
moi je sais que la foire aux livres a 1
euro c'est déjà noté dans mon agenda
d'accord
donc à toi tu vas avoir la pièce de
théâtre
ça peut être assez intéressant
elle fait l'unanimité
on en parlait en début d'émission du 23
au 26 février aura lieu la 7e édition du
Mondial d'improvisation junior attrape
et ce sont si jeunes Trappistes de tes
cliques tête qui représenteront la
France alors l'année dernière l'équipe
junior de déclicate s'était classé
deuxième lors du Mondial d'impro qui
avait lieu en Suisse est-ce que cette
année vous l'appréhendez comment
cette année moi j'ai envie de dire que
peu importe en fait le résultat le
principe ça va être de faire en sorte
que ces 6 improvisateurs trappistes et
en tout cas les trois autres délégation
et des vrais moments de partage dans la
patinoire se découvre découvrent leurs
jeux et à la fin peu importe le
classement en tout cas pour moi
dans l'ensemble nous ce qu'on veut c'est
faire un bon spectacle pour le public
yvelinois Baptiste donc vous vous avez
déjà participé l'année dernière est-ce
que cette année vous vous engagez
comment l'année dernière c'était quelque
chose d'incroyable je pense que cette
année ce sera pareil mais avant tout
enfin je trouve que c'est surtout des un
monde partage entre
entre on est 24 24 jeunes
de tous les de tout univers différents
même de la planète parce que bah il y a
des Américains donc c'est un peu
la Suisse la Belgique
et je trouve c'est vraiment un moment de
partage où on crée des personnellement
j'ai créé des vrais amitiés avec
des Suisses des Belges et des Québécois
qui même à l'heure actuelle même si bah
parfois un océan nous sépare et ben on
parle encore et c'est il y a quand même
des liens qui se créent très facilement
on va dire au-delà de la compétition
c'est aussi un moment de convivialité
c'est ça
que vous allez dormir tous ensemble il y
aura un jeune par nation c'est bien ça
exactement on investit les canards
d'hier donc dans la Base de Loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et on va on a
fait en sorte que les chambres
réunissent un jeune de chaque délégation
afin que la glace soit brisée au plus
vite et que tout se passe bien dans la
patinoire et donc vous aurez trois
matchs donc un face à la Belgique un
face au Québec et un la Suisse c'est ce
qu'il y a une nation que vous redoutez
plus qu'une autre
je pense qu'on redoute un peu toutes les
nations mais c'est vrai que le Québec me
fait un peu plus peur pourquoi parce que
a été créé au Québec ils ont ça dans le
sang ils sont pratiquement nés avec du
coup c'est vrai que j'ai un peu plus
peur mais je pense que ça va bien se
passer et puis on est là pour s'amuser
dans tous les cas donc
est-ce que il y a des manières
d'improviser différemment en fonction de
son pays oui en fait c'est c'est le
rapport à la tête à la théâtralité
pardon à l'humour aussi on n'a pas le
même humour en France en Belgique Suisse
et au Québec et donc finalement ça fait
un joyeux bazar dans la patinoire le
temps de s'appréhender et puis surtout
ce qui est génial pour l'improvisateur
c'est que c'est que on est entre
déstabilisation
un confort et plaisir et souvent ça nous
ça nous permet de créer des nouvelles
choses et alors qu'on s'y attendait
vraiment pas donc donc finalement c'est
un inconfort plaisant et vous vous
préparez différemment en fonction des
équipes que vous allez affronter ou pas
vous connaissez un peu leur manière de
jouer pas du tout on est vraiment pas
sur un entraînement sportif où on va
cibler en fonction des attaques des uns
et les autres non vraiment pas nous on
est sur la l'approche théâtrale et on
fait en sorte de travail des notions qui
vont être importantes par rapport au
public et par rapport à l'autre qu'on a
dans la patinoire donc le fait de parler
fort le fait de pas refuser une
proposition qu'on nous a donné en face
le fait de toujours être face public
et encore développer un imaginaire en
fonction d'une catégorie donc ça ça oui
on travaille mais appréhender un jeu
québécois ou un je suis pas du tout en
tout cas pas nous alors comment est-ce
que ça se prépare en fait de
l'improvisation vous avez donné quelques
quelques aspects là mais finalement de
l'improvisation ça se prépare oui et non
on prépare jamais l'improvisation
on ne sait pas ce qu'on ce qu'on va
jouer on n'est pas dans le barillet de
l'arbitre parce que je l'arbitre prépare
des thèmes des catégories qu'on ne
connaît pas avant qu'elle soit dites
devant le public par contre ce qu'on
fait c'est que ben on se retrouve de
manière hebdomadaire on a un atelier de
2h tous les vendredis dans les locaux de
déclicité théâtre où là en fait ce qu'on
va apprendre à nos jeunes c'est bah à
partager à accepter le fait de dire oui
finalement c'est une notion pas si
facile le fait de partager son
imaginaire de de laisser aller son
imaginaire parce qu'on a des tendances
un peu à s'autosensurer et finalement on
apprend qu'en impro toutes les idées
sont bonnes à prendre et qu'il y a
jamais de mauvaises réponses il y a de
très bons accidents par contre alors
est-ce que j'ai comment comment est-ce
que vous avez été sélectionné pour ce
Mondial d'improvisation comment on a
sélectionné l'équipe
peut-être que Baptiste ou non capable au
sein de la compagnie du coup on est 15
il me semble quelque chose comme ça 14
juniors et c'est du coup c'est des
gluten qui organise le Mondial donc il y
a une sélection de trois garçons trois
filles donc qui du coup pour constituer
l'équipe à l'intérieur de des 14 joueurs
et donc
on a su ça il y a un mois et demi
quelque chose comme ça donc trois
garçons trois filles et bah voilà après
c'est nous les coachs donc Alexandra
feignez qui est comédienne aussi avec
qui théâtre et moi même qui sommes les
coachs de l'équipe junior qui avons
sélectionné ces 6 joueurs en fonction de
leur univers de jeu en fonction de aussi
le degré de sociabilité parce qu'on va
pas se mentir c'est une grosse colonie
de vacances sur quatre jours sur les ans
etc et finalement on a on a fait en
sorte que cette équipe soit équilibrée
tant dans la patinoire qu'en dehors de
la patinoire et alors qu'est-ce qui vous
anime en fait dans l'improvisation
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes dit bah je
vais faire de l'improvisation moi j'aime
particulièrement en pro parce que je
peux changer de personnage durant les
une ou deux minutes d'impro bah je suis
plus dans le cas je suis quelqu'un
d'autre je suis Émilie je suis Sandrine
et c'est ça que j'aime bien de pouvoir
oublier ces problèmes pour être dans une
patinoire et faire rire le public
c'est ça que j'aime bien et vous
Baptiste
au quotidien je suis pas non plus timide
mais ça me permet vraiment de
pour un extérioriser et me faire plaisir
sur quelque chose que
j'ai pas l'habitude de faire c'est à
dire que je me verrais rarement au
quotidien je voulais une princesse
et on impro bah tout est possible donc
ça m'est arrivé de jouer une princesse
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé des des
catégories du coup là vous avez aucune
idée de des catégories sur lesquelles
vous allez devoir improviser alors si
les catégories on les connaît il y a 15
catégories qui ont été sélectionnés par
la compagnie des clips théâtres et
celle-ci on les a transmises aux autres
équipes pour qu'on puisse tous les
travailler avant le Mondial après on ne
sait pas sur lesquels de ces 15
catégories on tombera ça ce sera à la
surprise chaque soir de spectacle il y a
une catégorie sur Molière où Shakespeare
il me semble exactement on a cette année
on a à la manière de Molière à la
manière de Shakespeare comme vous l'avez
déjà dit on a aussi à la manière des
œuvres de George Orwell on aura aussi à
la manière d'un numéro de clown ou
encore la manière avec l'accompagnement
musical donc à la manière des oeuvres de
Charlie Chaplin finalement
ça fait panel très très large sur
lesquelles chacun des 24 joueurs peuvent
trouver chaussures à leurs pieds et donc
trouver un moyen d'expression alors
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez choisi ces
personnalités là ces joueurs là oui
parce que finalement ils étaient très
complémentaires tous les 6 on en a fait
aussi des choix rapport à des juniors
qui l'année prochaine seront sortants
donc c'est à dire qu'ils auront fini
leur cursus avec nous donc histoire qui
vivent en événement important comme
celui-ci et parce que oui c'est un
moment qu'on a envie de partager avec
eux à ce moment-là de leur parcours
Baptiste nanka est-ce que si je vous
demande de faire une petite
improvisation vous êtes partant ou pas
pourquoi pas si je vous demande
d'improviser un JT une émission télé on
peut faire si on peut faire un JT si
vous voulez
allez-y
on a un peu proche pour faire un JT mais
ou sinon je me mets là-bas c'est
possible de mettre là-bas
on vous laisse vous mettre dans
l'ambiance
faut que je regarde là-bas c'est ça
mesdames et messieurs bonjour
Aujourd'hui
j'ai oublié la date
on est le jeudi 9 février je vais
recommencer
mesdames et messieurs bonjour
aujourd'hui jeudi 9 février nous
recevons Nantes cas aujourd'hui
dans le cas va nous parler de son
travail elle est infirmière et souffre
de difficultés financières aujourd'hui à
cause de covid-19 et de la grève des
transports car elle ne peut plus se
déplacer à son lieu de travail donc
quand pensez-vous en effet je n'ai pas
mon permis du coup je ne peux pas aller
en voiture à mon travail ce qui est très
handicapant et la grève a eu un fort
impact dans ma vie car je ne peux plus
aller à mon travail donc je ne peux plus
avoir mon salaire donc je ne peux plus
nourrir ma famille et faire mes courses
et c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de moi
aussi faire la grève comme ça s'il n'y a
plus de transport il n'y aura plus
d'infirmière merci dans le cas passons
tout de suite au sujet d'actualité
numéro 2 donc
je pense que j'ai plus d'autre chose
merci à vous bravo pour cette
introvisation qui a été vraiment
improvisée comme ça au dernier moment
alors en parlant d'improvisation il y a
un quiz qui a été fait spécialement sur
Déclic Théâtre alors moi je ne sais rien
de ce quiz mais comme d'habitude mais
c'est Nicolas dandry qui vient avec
Grégory canalet bonsoir qui a préparé ce
Queen je suppose que nous inviter de
décrypter après reconnaissent cette
tenue n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
je peux vous le dire
ouais voilà
des ardoises de jeux donc que je vous
explique un peu les règles pour ce quiz
spécial attendez je vous la porte
Grégory donc d'un côté nous avons
L'Équipe TV 78
non pas de guerre quoi que ce soit bon
d'accord et de l'autre côté les clips
déclics donc nous sommes sur un match
Déclic Théâtre conte TV 78 Mathilde vous
êtes la présentatrice vous êtes tout
seul
alors le règlement les questions vont
être posées vont s'afficher vous aurez
le temps d'écrire la réponse sur votre
ardoise vous attendez dès que je vous
dis vous montrez vos réponses et donc ce
n'est pas un quiz de rapidité c'est bien
un quiz et bien il peut y avoir égalité
à la fin voilà si vous trichez les
cartons rouges alors je sais que ça
c'est finalement ce sont les fiches pour
voter c'est ça c'est le public ça c'est
sur nos cartons de vote habituellement
moi je m'en sers aux cartes rouge ce
soir si il y a des tricheurs j'enlève
des points voilà alors on va commencer
avec la première question c'est parti
donc l'idée en fait c'est de savoir
quand est-ce qu'a été créé enfin pardon
où a été créé le le théâtre
d'improvisation
[Musique]
en 19
on a la date aussi
Québec Québec Canada c'est bien vous
écoutez bien vos invités
on va voir la réponse
0,5 points de bonus alors donc en fait
effectivement ça a été créé au Québec en
1977 exactement voilà par deux comédiens
qui s'appelle Robert Gravel et Yvon
lEducation
vous avez un point important
on va voir à la fin allez deuxième
question je vous propose de regarder cet
extrait qui date de 2003 nous sommes en
plein match d'improvisation entre les
juniors de trappes et de plaisir à la
mairie regardez
[Musique]
nombre de joueurs un par équipe ambiance
électrique à la Merise ce mardi pour le
gala d'ouverture de la 4e édition des
vacances de l'impro à Trappes sur la
patinoire les équipes junior d'un pro de
trappes et plaisir dans les tribunes les
jeunes susceptibles de suivre les
ateliers d'un pro l'enjeu de cette
rencontre s'amusait certes mais aussi
donner un aperçu de l'improvisation
théâtrale la question qui suis-je le nom
exact s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
qui suis-je et je peux vous dire qu'il y
a des dossiers si vous regardez les
images il y a des dossiers ce soir
voilà des dossiers ce soir sur tv78
réutilisables évidemment pour les
prochains matchs pro alors les réponses
pardon pour l'écriture j'écris très
bonne nouvelle
réponse pour TV 78 et bonne réponse pour
l'équipe Déclic Théâtre donc on a les
devoir aller chercher Janane bodili qui
est toute jeune sur cette image Janane
qui a été chroniqueuse télé en fait
c'est pour ça que j'ai cru que vous
allez vous demander ça
mais vous allez voir donc nous reviens
qui Louise dit Nono figure historique de
Déclic Théâtre il a commencé l'impro en
troisième après une rencontre avec Alain
de bois alias papi
allez troisième question un nouvel
extrait nous sommes en 2004 les cadets
les juniors de Déclic Théâtre sont
invités au Festival dans les nuages un
événement organisé par l'association
nuage France pour valoriser le travail
artistique des jeunes et des
associations dans les quartiers regardez
cette extrait bon je comprends en
capitaine c'est une si nous sommes au
premier étage c'est déjà impressionnant
vous êtes pas au deuxième encore hein
[Musique]
question très compliquée je vous
l'accorde et où est-ce que ça se déroule
en fait
waouh où est-ce que ça se déroule on a
bien écouté papi au début l'arbitre il y
a un indice et c'est dans un monument
[Musique]
on va regarder les réponses
s'il vous plaît
château de Versailles première étage
Tour Eiffel Paris
c'est un monument écoutez on va écouter
cet extrait
de venir ça m'a quand même fait plaisir
de venir faire un match un peu au
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel
bonne réponse de Déclic Théâtre donc
nous sommes à Paris
quatrième question direction le théâtre
des Blancs Manteaux à Paris nous sommes
en 2005 et je vous propose de regarder
ce spectacle avec des comédiens
historiques de décrypter
[Applaudissements]
vous entendez les enfants il y a des
salles comme ça qui véhiculent qui
véhicule tout un passé à artistique
sympa et puis comme comme je fais
également du café théâtre pour moi ça a
toujours une signification assez
assez forte de jouer au blanc
qui est cet homme qui est cet homme
c'est un humoriste
j'ai
vu votre réponse s'il vous plaît
Mathilde Franco le but n'est pas de
recopier des questions s'il vous plaît
et donc oui oui c'est ça il s'agit bien
de Arnaud de Arnaud de sa mère pardon
Arnaud de sa mère avec la petite Arnaud
de sa mère Arnaud de sa mère originaire
de 50 ans donc la technique théâtre
voilà allez regardez ces images une
finale d'un match l'impro dans les
années 90 d'un côté vous avez les rouges
et noir ce sont les noflats dans les
baptisé comme ça de l'autre les noirs et
blanc ce sont les facultron on est dans
les années 90 on allait chercher très
loin sur TV 78 c'était un derby à
l'époque les nopark passons facult trou
pardon et alors qui sont-ils en fait
c'est qui les naufleurs c'est qui les
facultés
[Musique]
c'est de l'histoire là on est vraiment
dans l'histoire de Déclic Théâtre
d'ailleurs puisque c'est des thématiques
cette année pour le Championnat du Monde
moi j'ai choisi à la manière de Pierre
Perret parce que ce soir vous saurez
tout tout sur et bien déclicitez
j'en ai qu'un sur les deux
trompettes de Sky Mathilde
de Déclic Théâtre effectivement les
naufleurs étaient deux trappes donc
c'était l'équipe en fait et bien de
Déclic Théâtre Les noflats de trappes et
donc on va voir tout de suite l'extrait
pour voir la réponse
vendredi 27 juin ce jouet la grande
finale du City le championnat
départemental d'improvisation théâtrale
des Yvelines c'est à l'espace Coluche de
plaisir que devait se dérouler cette
finale derby qui opposait les mouflards
de Trappes ou facultron de l'Université
de Saint-Quentin une soirée mouvementée
en perspective avec deux équipes qui se
connaissent bien
allez cinquième question retour en 2001
lors de la finale des championnats de
France juniors des matchs d'impro
regardé cet extrait
[Applaudissements]
de l'impro c'est bien construit d'ici et
elle se développe beaucoup à Trappes et
je pense que bientôt tout le monde va
vouloir en faire quoi
dans l'oreille et le tout s'est passé de
là quoi ah mon Dieu
qu'est-ce qu'il y a Steven dit qu'elle
est un flop j'ai rien compris c'est quoi
la cloque bah je sais pas qu'est-ce que
c'est l'heure alors en Angleterre OK
aujourd'hui ces deux personnes nous font
beaucoup rire donc quels sont les deux
personnes que vous venez voir qui sont
bien connues aujourd'hui
[Musique]
une femme un homme
s'il vous plaît autour de la table pour
[Musique]
[Rires]
voilà donc
cette télé 78 toujours derrière mais
allez-y
victoire il reste une seule question on
arrive à la dernière question
une juste je vais vous dire la règle de
cette pour cette question vous allez
voir plusieurs personnalités dans
l'extrait qui suit en fait on mettra une
enchère combien de personnalités vous
êtes capable de me donner donc vous
notez pas encore mais vous allez me
donner on va voir l'extrait tout de
suite on regarde le Bataclan à Paris a
été pris d'assaut hier soir pour la
soirée exceptionnelle en faveur du
projet de la marmite imaginé par
l'association basée à Élancourt Jamel
Debbouze toujours fidèle assez racines a
suédérer autour de lui des artistes
comiques du moment des copains venus
gracieusement par solidarité envers un
projet culturel qui devrait notamment
permettre à la compagnie de recentrer
toutes ses activités en un seul lieu à
Trappes et d'accroître les formations
d'improvisation le public composé en
grande partie du jeûne venus de 50 ans
mais aussi de toute la région parisienne
n'a pas hésité à suivre Jamel pour aider
Déclic Théâtre bilan de l'opération près
de 200000 francs récoltés pour la
marmite il y a une vraie intention
heureuse de faire rire tous les gens
sont venus pour ça et on s'est bien
marré et en plus vous avez espèce
d'émotion de solidarité c'est bien c'est
toujours bien ça c'est un pote puis en
écrit ensemble un scénario donc je vais
le voir je connais la plupart des gens
qui étaient là je les aime bien je suis
venu avec plaisir voir ces gens-là quoi
alors combien de personnalités êtes-vous
capable de me donner 10
moi j'allais dire 6
6e
de me les donner c'est le point deux
points pour déclic puisque c'est une
question spéciale alors Jamel Debbouze
Alain Debois
Eric et Ramzy est-ce que ça fait deux
Eric et Ramzi 2 Jean-Pierre Bacri oui
Jean-Paul Rouve
Dieudonné oui
Pierre Palmade Gad Elmaleh Gad Elmaleh
on va voir tout de suite la réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
mais Grégory vous avez triché en fait
vous connaissez déjà toutes les
questions
je l'avais déjà vu ce reportage il y a
très longtemps
il me semble qu'il y a égalité bah du
coup on a égalisé ouais vous avez
égalisé
sur un match nul bravo bravo pour ce
questionnaire voilà ce mode déclic
juste du coup j'avais une dernière
question puisque on vient de jouer à ce
jeu avec vous sur déclicite ça
représente quoi pour vous peut-être
Grégory canalet qui est qui avait très
bien répondu à beaucoup de questions ça
représente quoi pour vous Déclic Théâtre
pour moi c'est indissociable de Trappes
voilà l'identité de trap et après bah
c'est des noms on les a vu s'afficher le
premier nom qui vient forcément à
l'esprit c'est Jamel Debbouze et l'autre
mot bien sûr c'est improvisation moi
c'est les premiers mots qui me qui me
vient à l'esprit Gabriel je suis assez
d'accord avec Grégory je pense que c'est
quand même un emblème dans les Yvelines
avec beaucoup de talents qui ont émergé
donc
Amel pour moi j'ai envie de dire coeur
parce que c'est ma c'est ma compagnie de
coeur c'est ma deuxième famille des
clips théâtres j'y travaille depuis
maintenant quelques années vu que je
suis j'y suis entrée en 2010 et c'est
aussi encore beaucoup de partage puisque
je rencontre des nouvelles personnalités
ces jeunes improvisateurs qui qui sont
déjà aujourd'hui capables de me mettre
une jolie fessée dans la patinoire donc
voilà j'ai hâte de partager d'autres
moments avec eux Baptiste
c'est très bizarre comme sensation mais
oui c'est ça c'est une deuxième famille
c'est je sais que les personnes que j'ai
rencontré
grâce à des filles théâtre
à mon avis il y en a plein que je
l'aurais jamais rencontré dans la vie de
tous les jours et qui aujourd'hui sont
font partie de mes amis donc et qui je
pense le restaurant tout le temps
à la pratique dans une patinoire on va
rencontrer nos meilleurs amis et je
trouve que cette phrase est très vraie
parce que aujourd'hui mes meilleures
amies avec qui je passe tous mes moments
c'est des personnes que j'ai rencontrées
rencontré grâce à des clips théâtre et
grâce à l'impro du coup ouais je dirais
famille Grégory
hier un atelier il y aura un reportage
qui va apparaître un peu plus tard j'en
profite pour faire ma propre pub et moi
c'est vrai ce que j'ai senti dans
l'atelier c'est une grande cohésion il y
a le mot famille qui est revenu entre
vous il y a quand même une cohésion on
la sent ça se ressent en tout cas de vu
de l'extérieur c'est vraiment après
c'est pour ça ça c'est le principe aussi
du des ateliers c'est de créer une
cohésion parce que bah tous les ans il y
en a qui sortent il y en a d'autres qui
arrivent dans un nouveau groupe du coup
le but c'est aussi d'essayer de
désintégrer au plus vite par exemple mon
cas est arrivé cette année avec nous
et j'ai l'impression qu'on l'a bien
accueilli quand même
très très fort en fait ce qu'on partage
on part on partage pas juste des moments
de spectacle on a enfin c'est ouais
c'est très fort et bravo déclité pour ça
et bien merci à vous pour ces mots
touchants on sent la famille on sent
l'émotion merci d'être venu et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions on va terminer
cette émission avec la chronique sur le
bien-être animal
[Musique]
nous avons on va être joint en plateau
avec par hatis Barret qui est
conseillère sur le bien-être animal pour
la ville de Poissy bonsoir à tous ce
soir
une entrée j'aime bien
avec un chien voilà alors comment il
s'appelle
petit frère à Paco et c'est le fils je
dirais puisque c'est un membre de la
famille le fils de Céline et Karl Olive
d'accord
vous allez parler vous nous parlez de
je prends mon côté animal ce soir dans
dans l'émission voilà
mais alors juste avant j'aimerais
revenir avec vous sur le prix que vous
avez reçu pour la ville de Poissy vous
avez aussi le label Ville ami des
animaux les abeilles de pâtes alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
mot qu'est-ce que c'est ce label alors
ce label en fait c'est ça a été mis en
place par par la Région Île-de-France
donc qui a mis en place le label Ville
ami des animaux et en fait elle a voulu
accentuer sur trois axes ces trois axes
sont promouvoir le respect du bien-être
animal valoriser la place de l'animal en
ville et renforcer le lien de l'animal
de compagnie auprès de nos citoyens en
fragilisés voilà il fait très possessif
et donc vous avez reçu ce prix de la
part de Valérie Pécresse de la
Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France voilà tout à fait donc en
fait toutes les villes peuvent
participer la ville de Poissy a
participé pour la première fois et donc
on j'ai eu le label avec la mention de
pas de place sur trois pour une première
participation donc il y a d'autres
communes des Yvelines qui ont reçu ce ce
prix ville ami des animaux alors
Saint-Germain-en-Laye a reçu les
encouragements du jury mort par réseau
et Andrésy ont tenu le label une pâte
chante-nous les vignes Coignières
plaisirs Vélizy-Villacoublay
vernet-sur-seine et carrière sous Poissy
ont aussi eu le label de pâtes et enfin
Montesson a obtenu le label 3 pattes
alors on va revenir un petit peu sur sur
l'idée de cette chronique vous allez
nous parler de propreté des animaux du
chien et du chat alors est-ce qu'il faut
laver son chien ou son chat alors ben
écoutez en fait moi ce que je veux faire
d'abord vous poser la question autour de
la table une question est-ce que à chaud
comme ça vous pensez qu'il faut laver
son chien ou son chat en posant juste
[Musique]
oui ou non de manière naturelle moi j'ai
envie de dire
[Musique]
pas trop enfin ils font leur toilettes
eux-mêmes voilà bah écoutez
en fait il y a pas de bonne réponse ou
de mauvaises réponses tout le monde a
tout le monde a raison il y a pas de
règle
les animaux n'ont pas les mêmes besoins
que les humains ils n'ont pas besoin
d'être lavés tous les jours puisque en
fait leur peau peut être fragilisée par
un lavage très fréquent tout dépend en
fait de l'environnement leur
environnement intérieur extérieur voilà
et alors du coup concernant les chats
est-ce qu'il faut les laver alors
concernant les chats ce sont des animaux
propres on dit même l'expression la
toilette la toilette de chat les chats
ça dépend également de l'environnement à
chacun au micro parce que sinon on va
plus vous entendre un chat qui en
surpoids c'est comme les animaux le
surpoids c'est pas bon donc il va avoir
du mal à accéder à certaines parties de
son corps donc on va lui proposer de lui
faire une toilette concernant bah
écoutez un chat qui va avoir des puces
oui on va lui proposer de faire une
toilette le chat qui a des poils longs
ou qui a des nœud dans les poils oui on
va lui proposer de on va l'aider à faire
sa toilette et alors pour les chiens
comment ça se passe alors pour les
chiens le lavage est un peu plus
fréquent concernant en concernant les
chiens on peut le laver donc toutes les
toutes les quatre semaines tout dépend
également de son activité donc quand il
fait très chaud pendant la canicule bien
sûr va falloir laver son chien un chien
qui va rentrer de balade bah il va avoir
de la boue sur lui donc oui on va lui
proposer un bain et puis bah voilà le
l'habituer l'habituer tôt vous pouvez
commencer ce que je vous conseille c'est
de laver votre chien après l'âge de
trois mois comme ça il pourra faire ses
défenses immunitaires et ça va lui
éviter de d'avoir un rhume ok
[Rires]
alors comment comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour habituer son chien à prendre un
bain parce que souvent c'est quand même
un moment qu'ils apprécient pas trop
alors c'est c'est une bonne question en
fait il vous est toujours de très bonnes
questions pas de stress pas de stress
pas de précipitation déjà donc on
prépare son chien on lui démêle les
poils avec
moi
il est poli un chien très poli
donc on lui démêle d'abord les poils de
l'eau tiède une bonne ambiance
n'hésitez pas à donner une friandise
donc
surtout on fait attention au prochain
point pas de pas de shampoing pour pour
chat au niveau du chien pas du shampoing
pour animal pour humain au niveau pour
pour son chien
pas de shampoing dans les yeux pour les
oreilles on fait attention pour éviter
l'outil ça peut ça peut arriver vous
séchez bien au niveau de son ventre au
niveau de ses pattes j'ai allumé sa
serviette peut-être qu'il pense qu'il va
prendre un bain
de préserver nos micros surtout jamais
d'eau de Javel pas de produits
hydroalcoolique parce que des
informations comme ça qui circulent sur
sur des réseaux sociaux jamais de
produits s'il vous plaît dangereux c'est
pas bon pour la santé du chien alors
Rocky qui est là qui vous fait plein de
bisous il me semble propre enfin en tout
cas il est très propre et lui ça lui
pose pas de problème le bain alors lui
voilà c'est la particularité c'est pour
ça que j'ai choisi c'est un chien qui
est très propre et il se la folie parce
que il fait du jogging il entraîne de
son maître grâce à lui son maître
monsieur car le livre il a fait beaucoup
de progrès au niveau de du jogging et
puis il reçoit beaucoup de caresses
il y en a beaucoup de femmes
est-ce que vous avez des animaux autour
du plateau non pas du tout
ouais j'ai un beagle à la maison
ou pas
[Musique]
merci beaucoup en tout cas à tous pour
toutes ces précisions n'oublions pas les
animaux
tous les membres de la famille il faut
prendre soin d'eux voilà merci en tout
cas il vous a fait votre toilette à vous
est-ce que ça vous intéresse de savoir
la météo de demain
et maintenant tout de suite la météo à
suivre de vendredi
demain matin le ciel sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble du département mais plutôt
bonne nouvelle les températures
remontent un peu on ne sera plus en
dessous de 0 degré il fera 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 3 degrés à Houdan
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
et laisser la place au soleil comptez
environ 9 degrés dans le secteur de
Mantes-la-Jolie 8 degrés à Houdan et 7
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et
pour ce week-end quel temps fera-t-il
Gabriel est-ce qu'on aura du soleil et
bien du soleil oui Mathilde mais les
températures restent fraîches ce
week-end samedi matin le temps sera
nuageux avec des températures comprises
entre 3 et 4 degrés l'après-midi même
tendance côté ciel les températures se
réchauffent légèrement il fera 7 degrés
à Rambouillet 8 degrés à Versailles et
Houdan et 9 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
dimanche le soleil est de retour sur le
département compté dans la matinée 6
degrés à Versailles ou dans et
Rambouillet et 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie l'après-midi peu de
changements les températures seront
comprises entre 6 et 8 degrés merci
beaucoup Gabriel c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]